tout crin
fatima zahra aussi appelé lazara vous
fait sensation sur le web un malheur en
france et vous avez juste un premier
album ça va vite et bien comment vous
voyez ça ça va très vite là bas en
france 1 c'est comme tu peux te des
abonnés sur instagram petit fils né pour
un si gros sabots un jour tu après même
moi j'avais vraiment une des précises
puis je pense que c'était un vent de
fraîcheur pour eux aussi puisqu'ils ont
vu que j'étais moi je travaille jour et
nuit zombies que j'avais faim puis en
fait on est surréaliste c'est vraiment
ils ont misé sur moi comme j'ai misé sur
eux des gens vous êtes né à montréal
mais votre histoire ressemble plus à un
conte de fées parce qu'en 2016 que vous
rencontrez le producteur à montréal béni
adams tous les deux est un peu ivres et
vous chanter la chanson de céline dion
pour que tu m'aimes encore hélas à
cliquer comment ça s'est passé j'ai
chanté après je suis pas mal sûr que
j'ai pas très bien chanter mais
lycée c'est une personne qui avant de se
projeter c'est un visionnaire puis ma
vie au studio demain et de là on a
commencé à travailler travailler sur sur
plusieurs chansons et on a fait deux
prétendants qui a été ma première
chanson qui a sorti en france avec un
rapport sapin niro et c'est de là que
j'ai compris qu'il y avait peut-être une
possibilité pour moi d'avoir une
carrière dans la chanson
[Musique]
en train
on ne connaît pas au perrier de vous
vous êtes assez mystérieuse autodidacte
la formation donc en chant vous l'avez
développer comment ce talent
du tout
en écoutant mémé chanteuse préférée
vraiment j'ai étudié soit barbra
streisand ou barbara piaf
aznavour frank sinatra j'ai vraiment
appris à chanter en écoutant leurs
chansons j'ai appris à écrire aussi en
écoutant en écoutant leurs chansons mais
c'est aussi simple que cela est simple
le tilt que vous avez pratiqué beaucoup
dans un salon de coiffure où vous avez
travaillé c'est vrai ça
oui en fait c'est que je mettais
justement ma playlist avec mes chansons
d'antan et ça ça travaille le règne donc
à force d'écouter ça toute la journée
c'est sûr que on commence à comprendre
la formule mathématique d'une chanson
les choses sont rendement de la première
note qu'on entende
on est soufflé
vient d'où cette voie lors de ce don
lorsque vous qu'on sait que c'est un
donc c'est sa force de travail et c'est
à
les deux je pense je sais que
si vous demandez à certains de mes amis
ça fait 10 ans yvon duhamel a chanté
comme une casserole et c'est vrai je
sais pas si c'est
j'ai perçu quelque chose dans ma voix et
je les travaille est en fête et moi je
peux je pense que c'est un don mais
c'est aussi beaucoup de travail si
j'essaie de de
demain signé à moi même comment comment
atteindre certaines notes et et voilà
mais je pense que j'ai encore beaucoup
de chemin à faire et je sais que j'ai
pas au plus haut de mon potentiel vote à
moi
votre musique est un mélange d'edith
piaf yeux du hip hop là dedans la
musique arabe aussi pourquoi vous
mélangez tout ce que ça vient de vos
racines familiales j'ai grandi avec
toutes ces
influences musicales mam a coûté miku la
musique arabe à la maison j'ai jamais ni
mes racines parce que parce que 20 mes
parents nous ont quand même élevé avec
avec les valeurs de de leur pays mais je
suis né et j'ai grandi au québec donc
c'est mes racines aussi je me vois
québécoise
jamais entendu
ça fait quand même un bon mélange à
l'afrique du nord où je jouais niveau
parra et puis le québec finalement ouais
ouais les mélanges say say say say
toujours jolie
[Musique]
touche
je sais que la première à première vue
c'est un peu un mélange bizarre parce
qu'on se dit comment est ce qu'on peut
mélanger une valse et rajouter des
alouettes mais
ça s'est vraiment fait naturellement
après je pourrai pas l'expliquer c'est
une cité in et puis moi et beignets on a
réussi à
rapporter ce nouveau george président
fatima zahra el azara merci beaucoup
merci à vous je dis souvent ça va
ma
dalleau
dans mon
ne sut pas suffi de joie
ou